[Music]
I'm Mark halin and I'm John Hilman with
all due respect to Amtrak seems like you
all have an itty bitty problem with your
branding they're called the asella
primaries but what does that mean for
what's build as the ASA primary for
what's build as AA is that how you say
it for what's build as the asela primary
the
primary the ASA primary The Accelerated
primary is it a cellat train Melissa yes
aelin what some are calling the acelia
primary the Acela acella primary what
some are calling the uh AEL primary okay
anyway aella aella Amtrak primary it's
been called a lot of different things
today so named because Amtrak's famous
asalat Trin Amtrak's famous asol Trin
the esa the primaries the Asa primary
Amtrak's famous cilia train it's called
the acce laa
[Music]
primary
you happy ACA primary day sports fans
today voters in five Northeastern states
Pennsylvania Connecticut Delaware Rhode
Island and
Maryland get their say in the
presidential nomination race and all
signs point to another very Victorious
evening for Donald J Trump billionaire
and Hillary R Clinton not quite
billionaire unless the public polling is
way way off the question tonight is not
whether the Front Runners will win all
five contests but how thumping Le they
will do so at this stage in the race
margin is master so let's start with the
Republican side there are 172 delegates
up for grabs tonight and a whole lot of
bragging rights so mark
what would make this a great night for
Donald Trump and what would make this a
super duper Mega Mondo night for Donald
Trump 15 contests less five of them are
tonight yeah these ACA States our
colleague steveo has done a brilliant
job of crunching the numbers and looked
at different scenarios of how Trump
could do in the five states of course as
with all we've all learned now these
states have different rules right under
Steve's scenario and I and I I've
crosschecked his work Trump's worst
night could have you to do that Trum
worst night barring some extraordinary
surprise we're not expecting he'll win
all five states his worst night gets him
over the number that the other campaigns
have looked at and said if he gets that
many he's he's ahead of the pace he's
closer to being in position to get a
majority oh I'm not going to disagree
with you on that that I feel as though
you know if he is in the worst case
scenario he could be under 100 delegates
under 100 delegates he'd still have to
get 60% according to Steve yino of the
remaining delegates after tonight that
would still that would make it more of
an uphill fight whereas you would but
he's not going to do that bad is the
point the worst the worst Cas but but
you know you look at Maryland there's
some districts around the Washington
area do well where Kasich might Kasich
might pick off some delegates given the
Rhode Island rules Trump's not going to
win them all but other than that well
yeah then there's Pennsylvania so Ben
Ginsburg the noted Republican lawyer and
MSNBC analyst I had friend of ours
friend of ours had a little dispute this
morning I say any pledged unpledged
delegate who says has said publicly I'm
going to vote with my district any of
them
who who who Trump wins their District I
think it would be very hard for them not
to vote for
Trump let me ask you whether I count
them as practically let me ask you
whether you think you think Trump's
going to win all of the congressional
districts in Pennsylvania yeah okay so
what I think is the case with a lot of
those delegates we should just explain
this there's I mean because it's the
only confusing thing of the night 71
delegates in Pennsylvania 177 win or
take all Statewide the other 54 are
Unbound delegates and I know the bell
rang but those guys some of them have
said what you said others have said
they're inclined to vote with their
congressional district and Trump may
lose a district or two but the point Hy
the one thing we're not going to know at
the end I'm going to count some of the
unpledged tonight you can do whatever
you want all right we've also spent the
day crunching the data on the Democratic
side there are on that side 384
unpledged delegates at State tonight as
Hillary Clinton tries to turn more and
more her attention to the general
election and to Donald J Trump
billionaire Bernie Sanders says he's
staying in the race until the end no
matter what anyone's advocat suggest so
John same question about Clinton she's
going to win tonight
big what would constitute a good night
and what would constitute a super great
night for Clinton well you know if she
first of all she got to win all five and
although we all assume she's going to
win all five there's some chance that
she could lose Rhode Island there's a
chance of that both campaigns concede
that point as you know Tad Divine in
this room suggested that the Sanders
campaign had some optimism about
Pennsylvania the public polling still
has them about 10 points apart it's not
totally impossible uh that Sanders could
pull off a Michigan thing in
Pennsylvania if Hillary Clinton lost one
or two states tonight you know she would
not suffer much in terms of delegates
but she could suffer a fair amount in
terms of that her being able to slam the
door shut on Sanders rhetorically that
would be a bad night for her winning all
five and winning them all by double
digits that would be a great night and
the delegates thing doesn't matter that
much because it's because they're
proportional it's not going to make that
difference much of a difference either
way it's all about more about rhetoric
here tonight than about delegates that's
what I think I mean I said I said
unpledged delegates we're talking about
pledge delegates at State tonight I
think for Clinton she's in Pennsylvania
she's in Philadelphia I clearly she's
going to refer to the convention and her
Victory night speech to me this is about
the Clinton giving a speech which
continues to embrace Sanders supporters
which continues to ease Sanders out of
the race which continues to show appeal
to the whole Coalition of Democratic
party and talk about the theme she wants
to run on in the general election to be
clear though there's some some news
today some suggestion that the that's
Bernie Sanders might quote again
reassess we're now talking a little bit
again about reassessing the campaign
after tonight's results and it's seems
to me that if Hillary Clinton for
instance won all five and won all five
by double digits not inconceivable that
she could do that that would give
Sanders a kind of pause that would be
different than than than he what he
would leave if he won one state or if he
kept it really close in all five I'm
just talking about l in that case about
the momentum and the psychology than
just about the math the Clinton people
have been looking forward to this day if
she has if she has a great night her
greater night 225 delates 225 delegates
then for Sanders to explain how can be
nominated is a much more torturous thing
involving delegates super delegates and
pledge delegates at that point it's
possible that what he has not faced up
until now he would start to face which
is real questions about why are you even
in this race mathematically it's not
there on in a real way it's not there
now barring some unforeseen
circumstances I don't mean I don't think
that means he'll get him out I'm not
sure that even means he'll R out his
rhetoric but I do think the clintons
would rather run under those
circumstances with the Press believing
this is now of completely lost cost
right you know you know what's really
presidential Twitter trolling at 6:42 in
the AM that was the hour today that
Donald J Trump billionaire took to the
social media again to blast the alleged
campaign collusion between Ted Cruz and
John Kasich in Indiana where Trump wrote
quote the Cruz Kasich pact is under
great strain this joke of a deal is
falling apart not being honored and
almost dead and then the patented Trump
exclamation very dumb with the
exclamation point yesterday we talked on
the show about how the anti-trump treaty
fits nicely into the front runers
framing of the race as a rigged deal but
this morning John Kasich pH phoned into
the Today's Show and put forth a
vigorous defense of the strategy the
alliance The Pact as perfectly above
board listen Matt this whole business is
about stopping Hillary Clinton from
being president I have laid out a
strategy and I have not told anybody to
not vote for me I'm just not there
campaigning and you know what when you
don't campaign in certain areas in any
kind of a race guess what your turnout
goes down I don't tell people how to
vote I am not in that state right now
but I will be in other states and I will
be at the convention in a broken
convention trying to become president of
the United States because I have the
record and the capability to carry out
the job and win in the fall so Mark I
bet John K was happy to see that picture
of himself from like 1986 there on the
Today's Show um looking they looking
very young um how do you think Kasich
and Cruz are doing it selling this deal
now more than 24 hours in I continue to
be amazed at how poor job they're doing
Trump's doing a great job attacking it
the Press agrees with Trump's analysis
more and more and both I look I think
the Kasich and crew staffs did a good
job of putting the deal together
belatedly it was a smart thing to do but
the two candidates continue to act like
they're trying to sabotage it their
their their rhetoric is a bad process
they're not turning the attention to
issues of care the middle-class voters
would care about and workingclass voters
would care about I think I think they
have really undermined the possibility
that this will work through the
candidate's failure to explain this in a
way that's optimistic uplifting
passionate horrible and away from
process they've been horrible they've
been horrible in slightly different ways
Cruz has been all the things you've said
which I think is process driven and
negative rather than positive Kasich has
just been defensive and weird and
inexplicable I mean I think the way
Kasich has talked about this has been
almost incomprehensibly there's two
there's two possibilities either the
staff brief the candidates on what to
say well there's three the staff briefed
the candidates what to say the
candidates ignored them two they didn't
brief them and the candidates are just
out there saying there or this is what
the staff wanted them to say none of
those are good possibilities they're all
bad I suspect they didn't brief them
because these guys are out there just
saying stuff look it's hard to sell
something like this in a positive way
you can imagine we can imagine better
ways than this for sure but it is hard
to sell this in a positive uplifting
optimistic way that doesn't end up being
on process because it's a weird thing to
do not many people are familiar with it
not many voters have seen it it would
take a lot of very a lot of
communications skills that um apparently
take they should have flooded The Zone
with surrogates who said we're doing
this because Donald Trump would be bad
for the Republican party and bad for
America forget the process what you need
to know is Donald Trump should not be
our nominee which of course is exactly
in a funny way like what the what the
the best of the rhetoric was best I mean
by best most effective of the rhetoric
was in Wisconsin which should be the
model for how this whole thing is going
to we want to empower voters to give
them the best choices that aren't Donald
Trump because Trump's just talking about
voters and they're talking about
all right when we come back a doy do of
guests a daisy chain of political
strategists in both parties just wait
till you see who we pair up on this show
after these words from our sponsors a
doy do and a
[Music]
da
Donald Trump uh in addition to being a
friend he's a brilliant businessman he's
a great celebrity knows how to milk that
for everything and he's a good
Entertainer so naturally he's getting a
lot of attention uh from the press and
from a lot of angry voters but uh no he
he will not be president he will not be
the nominee what would have to happen
for you to say man this Trump thinks for
real he'd have to win he'd have to he'd
have to go out and win Iowa would have
to go out and win New Hampshire and
today you put the chance of his winning
the Iowa caucuses at what percent zero
zero zero chance of winning New
Hampshire primary
zero that was two guys former McCain
adviser Charlie black who now is an
adviser to John case's campaign and
former Romney campaign strategist stort
Stevens who's not affiliated with any
presidential campaign the cycle both
have been guests on the show before both
have good senses of humor and both
showed as you heard there some
skepticism that Donald Trump would be
their party's nominee so we have him
back now to talk about the race
gentlemen thank you for joining you
obviously weren't the only two who were
doubt doubted that Trump would be the
nominee Charlie you've known Trump for a
long time Stewart I don't think you know
him at all or very well let me start
with you Charlie what's the single thing
you think you underestimated obviously
he's not the nominee yet but he's
obviously done better than either of you
thought he would so did you
underestimate something about Trump
about the electorate the other
candidates
what I I underestimated the extent to
which the Press would let Trump get away
with murder and and not speak to issues
or talk details on issues and uh frankly
the electorate is very angry may be more
Angry than I realize but I still don't
think he's going to be the nominee 62%
of Republicans have voted against him in
these primaries St what did you get
wrong to lead to the conclusion that
Trump wouldn't win Iowa wouldn't win New
Hampshire South Carolina
Etc um I I thought that there would be a
more focused effort on stopping Trump um
and not the idea that if you wait one1
uh to get him that that would be a good
thing
um he did lose Iowa he was weakened
there for a few days you I would have
thought that there would have been a
concentrated effort among the candidates
to focus on Trump and um try to stop him
um but there was in this crazy Lane
theory of campaigns where people were
trying to win their Lanes instead of
trying to win their races um and that
benefited Trump Charlie if you were
listening to this program uh just a few
minutes ago you would have heard The Two
Hosts here pretty harshly criticizing
the way in which your guy John Kasich
and Ted Cruz have been messaging this
Alliance that they've put together how
they've been explaining it how they've
been selling it um tell me whether you
think they have done a good job uh make
the case for why they've messaged it
well well John that's nice of you um I
am advised by smart people that you just
say Donald Trump shouldn't be the
nominee because he'd be bad for the
country but U listen this whole thing is
a Feeding Frenzy these are typical
tactics in multi candidate races it's
happened all the time for years U you
know as recently as last month at the
Michigan Republican convention the Trump
forces colluded with the Kasich forces
to deny delegates and committee spots to
Mr Cruz now I didn't hear a lot of
nashing of teeth out of Donald about
that so you know maybe uh maybe these
guys are tired of answering the question
but that's it Donald Trump would be bad
for the country and the fact is that he
can still be stopped but if we have
limited resources it's smart not to have
both campaigns spread them thinly across
the same state PL and simp but Charlie
don't you think that John Kasich just
listening to him talk about it saying
you know well I'm not telling my voters
what to do and I'm just this is just
about allocating resources and yet
talking about what he's done for the
last day as far as I can hear is talk
about process mostly and not really make
anything like as compelling an argument
even as you just made um I just doesn't
seem like he's that he really had a
clear idea about how to go out and sell
what is for most voters a relatively
complicated thing even though you're
right that there are these kind of
tactics that take place behind closed
doors all the
time John kasing does not like the talk
process and he and he doesn't like to
get into it he'd much rather talk about
issues his record where he wants to take
the country in the future he's not as
comfortable talking process but listen
this doesn't matter no voters are going
to decide to vote against either one of
these guys because they didn't message
correctly for 24 hours Stuart was this
deal a good idea for the Stop Trump
effort
sure yeah um you know I tend to think
that uh Indiana is the most important of
these I think it's important that Cru
wins Indiana and I I think when you kind
of cut through this the most important
thing is that uh John Kasich isn't uh
putting a big effort in Indiana and is
it really campaigning there and if
you're a voter sitting home in Indiana
that's probably what's going to sink
home the most to you that this is a a
Cru Trump Choice um and and that I think
will benefit uh Cruz um we'll see but I
I think that's going to be the real test
here in a week um and if if Cruz wins
that'll be good for those of us who
don't want Trump and if he doesn't
that'll be bad for us Charlie you've uh
been very close to Paul maniff for uh
your partner long time and Mr Trump
you've known for a long time as well
tell us what you make of their new
alliance well I think it was very smart
of Donald to bring Paul in he's a very
experienced uh manager and also an
experienced convention guy um the jury's
out on whether his advice will be taken
uh but it was a smart move on Donald's
part and Paul hasn't done this in a few
years so welcome welcome back Paul and
uh good luck with that candidate yeah
and from and from your perspective
what's in it for Paul maniff
for well Paul likes the game he enjoys
politics he's participated in many of
these convention mentions over the years
he just hasn't done one lately but I'm
I'm sure uh he believes in the guy and
would like to uh like to get another win
here but um NE nevertheless I think he's
going to have difficulty even getting
the nomination go ahead no good St you
know Paul Mani for as well do you think
uh his skills are are something that's
going to make Trump's chances of winning
not just a nomination but if he's a
nominee the general election more
likely yes um listen I think you have to
give Donald Trump credit here for
realizing that the team he had wasn't a
team that could get him uh to glory and
making changes um I have tremendous
respect for Paul maniff for uh one one
thing about I think you can say about
Paul is he will respect the difficulty
of the task and uh everybody who goes
through this process is ultimately humbl
by it if you win or you lose and I've
done both um and and you have to
approach it with the gravity
uh of the undertaking and I think Paul
is someone who will do that and now the
problem is he has to change an entire
culture um and there has been a culture
around Trump that is completely
antithetical to getting along with
others when they need to get along with
others antithetical to the idea that
they're going to win through uh addition
St I'm sorry I got problem I got to cut
you off we're going to say goodbye to
Charlie black Charlie thank you very
much for joining us I want to have you
back soon's going to stay with us
Charlie's going to hand the Baton off in
this Hall of Fame strategist relay to a
guy in the other La James Carville in
Louisiana will join us with St Stevens
right after
[Music]
this
would joined Again by former Romney
Chief strategist Stuart Stevens who's
not backing any candidates in this cycle
and with us now joining him is the raan
cinjun the guy who's squinting for
Clinton that would be James Carville
down there in Nola gentlemen good to see
you um James just we just been
discussing the pact the alliance between
Cruz and Kasich on the Republican side
just from a distance the Democratic
distance that you exist in does that
look like smart politics to you
strategically and tactically in terms of
stopping Trump you know when you behind
you you do things and nothing looks very
smart when you when you're behind and
they behind and they tried to do
something and it did it just didn't come
off very well but you know you just
don't want to sit there and get your
brains beat in you're going to try
something and it was you know it was
kind of fourth in 72 and they didn't
want to punt so they you know they flung
it up in the air didn't you know what
the most elegant paths I've ever seen
but I I can't blame them for trying they
were just up against the wall they got
to try something Stuart let's uh let's
just assume that that uh that that that
Donald Trump that this pack plays out um
over the course of the next few weeks we
go towards June 7th at this point what's
your prediction now is do you is your
view that Donald Trump is more likely
than not to get to 1237 delegates by
June 8th well you'd rather be Trump in
this process in anybody else it's like a
recount you'd rather be ahe going in um
you know I I think probably the best bet
is that Trump is going to be uh short uh
after California um I think Indiana is
going to be very important here um the
up and downside of tonight isn't that
great Trump's going to have a good night
uh even in the worst case scenario um I
would bet that Trump is is probably
going to be uh a 100 plus delegate short
uh after California that would be my bet
St would you still think that if Trump
won
Indiana um I think if Trump wins Indiana
it would be uh very psychologically
problematic for those opposing Trump S I
want to move over to the Democrats
before we have you hand the Baton off so
I ask you this how how would you
handicap a a possible Clinton Trump
general
election oh Clinton will crush Trump
there's there's no question um look and
just focus on one stat uh white women
Romney won white women by 14 Trump is
losing white women um he with with
Hispanics uh Republic Hispanics there's
not that many of them unfortunately and
he's got Trump has a 60% unfavorable
doesn't doesn't have the prospect of of
campaigning and turning some of those
numbers around I don't think it's very
good because Trump is so well known I
mean Ted Cruz is is losing to to Hillary
but losing by three Trump's losing by 10
that's a big difference it could be the
United States Senate plus uh you know
people don't know Cruz as well as Trump
Trump's been around forever um his
negative are really high and people who
that those who are for him are very
passionate about him but those who are
against him are very passionate there's
not a lot of Wishy wasi there to move
around in a campaign so I I I think
it'll be just an absolute uh Cakewalk
for Hillary
Clinton James um when you look at the
Poss the prospect I know you'll say that
you think that Hillary Clinton is the
prohibitive favorite against Donald
Trump if that's her opponent but what do
you think is the main thing she has to
worry about in that race what would be
the thing you'd be most concerned about
facing Trump as an opponent I mean you
know we're in a a change environment and
a change electorate and I think that the
thing that she has to do and she will do
to say that she represents change you
know the right kind of change I mean you
know I think that I agree with steart I
mean Trump goes in with with a with with
a with a lot to overcome and uh I just
think that she's got to execute and talk
about the things that she wants to do
how she wants to make the the the the
country different and how she you know
how she can be for change also I think
that's her biggest challenge and I think
she'll I think she'll be fine and and
you think there there's no sense there's
no way in which you think Trump U given
his his volatility that might be
something that that be psychologically
destabilizing for her just real quick
let me tell you everybody wants to say
Trump oh he's got a chance and
everything you know as I pointed out he
his whole this political thing started
with birtherism which is the most
asinine racist thing since George
Wallace ran for president and it's time
that somebody call him on it I'm going
to cut you off you're going to have a
chance to come back Stevens thanks for
doing this James Carville you stay there
Democratic strates needed done we join
us right when we come
[Music]
back
it would be a great idea to have a woman
uh as vice president and something I
would give very very serious thoughts of
are there any women in particular you
think would be qualified for that
job are there any women yes there are
many women who would be that
job no I think it's a little bit early
to be speculating on that uh but I think
you know as you know there are people in
in life today Elizabeth Warren I think
has been a real champion and standing up
for Working Families taking on uh Wall
Street that was Senator Bernie Sanders
on Morning Joe this morning we're back
now with longtime Clinton Ally James
carille who's in New Orleans and joining
us from our Washington Bureau former
White House communications director in
the Obama Administration Anita Dunn who
is not affiliated with either of the
presidential campaigns this year Anita
thank you for joining in taking the
Baton handoff from stort Stevens let me
start with you if you were advising the
Clinton campaign if Hillary Clinton
called you up and said what is the best
proper role for Bernie Sanders and his
supporters at my convention assuming she
gets a majority what would you tell her
that role should
be I would tell her let him make his
prime time speech let him talk directly
to to this country about the differences
between the two parties Mark as you know
um primaries are about fighting for the
direction of a political party but
general elections are about fighting for
the direction of an entire nation and I
think that Senator Sanders crime time
speech convention let him lay out the
indictment of the Republicans and the
difference between the two political
parties and speak directly to his
supporters and the people who've been
attracted to his message but she's not
calling me for advice yeah James what
what what the right what's the best role
from the Clinton point of view if she's
the nominee for Senator Sanders in
Philadelphia well I mean it's going to
be her convention but generally the
other candidates will be allowed to
speak and I you know I'm sure that all
that'll be negotiated you know going
into the convention but it's I sure
wouldn't discount the possibility that
Sanders would have a speech and a speech
at an important time during the
convention he's got a lot of a lot of
vote he's registered a lot of people
these are people that the Democratic
party needs to and they need to be
spoken to I mean
I I don't have a problem with that James
I'll stay with you just because you're
obviously you're for Hillary Clinton one
thing that is clear one thing that is
clear is that Senator Sanders has spoken
to Young Democrats young voters in a way
much more powerfully than secretary
Clinton has so far what what can she
take from Bernie Sanders what can she
learn from him what does she have to do
to get the affection uh the enthusiasm
of those voters well I'm around young
people a lot you know I'm a college
professor now and I think Sanders you
know it has a a a critique of the system
that is in in my opinion in in opinion a
lot of other people is kind of
superficial but it's appealing to to
people and they've coming in the party
and they have enthusiasm and I think any
political party wants you know wants
young people like this I mean I think
Democrats have a huge Advantage with
with people under 35 and he'll make it
better and part of the her ability as a
presidential candidate is going to be to
incorporate these people and have them
as enthusiastic members of the
Democratic Party which I hope she can do
I think she can but it's going to
require some some political still it's
going to require some some dexterity
it's going to require some patience and
I think she all of those things that
she'll demonstrate that she has Anita
you and I have talked in the past about
what are the issues that matter to
Millennial voters um what what can
Hillary Clinton do while staying true to
herself on policy and in terms of her
temperament and tenor to be able to
connect to those
voters you know I think it's interesting
because the issues that Bernie Sanders
is talking about are issues that I think
Hillary Clinton is very comfortable
talking about I mean Hillary Clinton has
about 30 years of experience of what
happens when you have moneyed interests
ganging up against Progressive issues
like health care for example she can
speak to that about as well as anybody I
think that she can speak to education
about as well as anybody she let
education reform when she was the first
lady of Arkansas no that what Hillary
Clinton has is a lot of areas of
agreement with Bernie Sanders and she
also has a passion for a lot of the
things that he's been talking about in
terms of you know making lives better
for regular people I think that's what
needs to come through in the general
election I think what James was saying
is absolutely right which is she needs
to talk to them but at the same time I
think she's got a lot to
say I think that these young people like
a lot of people AR think going need
agree with this they think the system is
rigged and she's got to convince them
that that that she understands that and
she's about leveling this playing field
I mean that she's going to be an
advocate for a point of view people
around the country and particularly
young people think the system is being
corrupted by money uh the you know and
and and she's got to be able to speak to
that and speak to it with some passion I
think she can do that I think she
believes that and I think that they're
going to have to do that she's got to
talk about that because that's what
that's what young people think they
think this thing is rigged and stacked
and bought off and you know to some
exent I can't blame him Anita once upon
a time there was a war room in Little
Rock Arkansas that had a sign on the
wall that said change versus more the
same don't forget Healthcare and the
other one was it's the economy stupid
that one got a lot of attention what are
the three things that should be tacked
on the wall of the Clinton war room for
the general election she's a
Nomine I don't think those three things
are a bad place to start to be honest I
change versus more of the same I would
change that a little which is change
versus going back backwards more of the
same vers is going backwards I think
that the way that she's going to match
up against Republicans the second is it
is the economy but it's about jobs it's
about your life and the third is it's
about them okay it's about the people
and I think that those three things you
know not as similar to what James tacked
up in his War Room in 1992 are really
the kind of core precepts moving forward
James we got just less than a minute
left what what would you put up in the
War Room in Brooklyn I I would say that
the the the change that we're going to
bring about is we're going to have a
government that works for you and and
we're going to take on the kind of
people that are working against you and
people got to feel like you know it's
it's it's a Level Playing Field out
there and I'm I'm going to level it for
you I'm going to be your person in the
white house and all of those things C
you need right it's a change us going
back I mean Trump wants to take us back
to
1958 that's not the way to go but I
think she's got to do that and she's got
to talk about how she wants to level of
playing field and how all of her life is
been about being an asent of change and
being on the on the Cutting Edge of
change and I think she can do that very
effectively I look forward to watching
it do it Jamis carille one thing I will
say for you is you've lost some of your
piness since 1992 because that none of
that's quite as py as the economy stupid
but it was great to have you on today
needed done always great to have you on
uh if you're watching us in Washington
DC uh we got to see these Lovel people
on the television you could also hear
them on the radio radio at Bloomberg
99.1 FM and we will be right
back
[Music]
he
here now are two of our Bloomberg
politics colleagues senior White House
reporter Margaret talv and our man on
the Republican convention coverage and
much else on the GOP side that would be
John McCormack lady gentlemen good to
see you Margaret um Hillary Clinton yeah
is going to do what if she uh wins big
as big tonight as people assume she's
going to win she GNA do what in terms of
how she handles Bernie Sanders hopefully
because what she's trying to do is
figure out how to bring them along she
will manage to finesse a message that at
once makes herself more inevitable and
has a touch of Grace for him and for his
supporters something that allows him to
feel good about himself something that
allows his fans to feel okay about her
while making clear as she did a little
more clumsily the night before in MSNBC
that she's winning so Donald Trump wins
five tonight let's say um are we going
to have finesse uh from Donald Trump of
the kind that Margaret is suggesting we
might get from Hillary Clinton I think
what we might get finessed tonight and
tomorrow morning it's sort of an
interesting day tomorrow for Trump
because he needs to be Statesman in the
morning and then he needs to be showman
in the evening when he goes to Indiana
with Bobby Knight so it's going to be
one of those days for Trump where you're
going to get the full
you know spectrum of the candidate in
this new evolved Persona this deal
between Cruz and Kasich has put a
spotlight on a reality which existed
before but is now really heightened
which is if Trump wins Indiana is it the
case that the air is going to come
completely out or almost completely out
of the stop drop movement yeah no I
think it's a huge State obviously and I
if I were cruise I would be praying for
a massive thunderstorm over the state of
Indiana tonight to knock out the power
the cable the internet so that they
don't hear anything about the results in
these primaries tonight I don't think
that's probably going to happen but uh
it's just there's so little time between
tonight and that primary it's going to
be very difficult to change the Dynamics
of the race in six
days what is on Hillary Clinton's to-do
list you know we talk about her turning
to the general election she's got to
pick a running mate plan the convention
how do you suspect she will spend this
time between now and the convention
obviously with the breakpoint coming in
first week of June after the last voting
yeah I think they're looking at a few
potential break points right and one is
once all the news organizations stop
paying attention to Bernie Sanders right
that's one second is endorsements that
aren't out yet third is Sanders himself
she's waiting for him to meet her maybe
not halfway but like 20% of the way
right it affects how she can react how
she can move things forward but they've
got to balance on her side two things
number one is how does she get things
right with him and number two and number
two is this Trump thing and that you
know right so talk about talk about
today the Sanders hits her for being
friends with Donald Trump what so that's
like not in the spirit of ratcheting
down it's a picture a photograph right
of both of the clintons with with a new
first time he's wielded that particular
weapon right incredible and you know
right at a time when he knows that she's
trying to calibrate how to reach out to
him and his supporters using language
like traitor in this in this news
release it was you know pretty
aggressive and at the same time more
signs from Tad Divine from his
strategist that there may be some sort
of a reassessment after tonight and so
it's really mixed messaging and it's
hard for her to figure out kind of had a
dance he's sort of all over the map he's
left some small openings to suggest that
he's beginning to rethink it and that
every time he almost gets there it's
like kapow you know we keep we keep
waiting for a trigger for more people
like Chris Christie and Jeff sessions to
get on board the Trump train prominent
people I don't suspect it's going to
happen after tonight Northeast but could
we see that after Indiana yeah I mean I
think if he wins Big in Indiana that
that could start to happen personally I
you know I thought the contested
convention thing was fairly likely 3
weeks ago like 70% something like that
but I'm I'm sort of down under 50% I
know you two gentlemen are still sort of
split on that topic but it it's to me
it's feeling like a you know probably
less than 50% probability at this point
I think it's pretty close to Binary if
if Trump wins Indiana I don't I think he
gets there if he doesn't win Indiana I I
don't know that he will I think that I
think the numbers add up that way we're
now in alignments yeah that's kind of
interesting good okay there's probably
not going to be a ton of point I think
still can if he loses Indiana I think he
still can but I think it's really hard
becom really pretty hard let me ask you
this question though just because you
were down at the RNC meeting last week
right and there was a lot of discussion
about how Paul Manford and the charm
offensive down there went since then
there's been walking back there's been
reports of turmoil in the Trump World
about things that Trum Trump feels about
things that maniford said down there how
does that all play with delegates as
they look at what seems to be a very
unstable situation and RNC members I
think RNC members uh you know went away
from that Gathering you know feeling
somewhat reassured but still very
skeptical and so they're going back to
their state parties and their state
parties are asking them about what's
going on with this Trump situation
what's going to happen in Cleveland are
we going you know so it's U I think it's
going to be you know he's going to need
to continually reassure the party
establishment and you know some of these
delegates have been picked many of them
haven't yet I see a lot of news releases
at Bill Clinton's doing events I never
hear anything that he says he doesn't
make the news former president United
States that's probably a good
but have you been covering him lately
have you been watching why is it that
he's making no news I I think they're
probably trying very hard to keep him
from making news right now because the
last few times he's making news he's
really taking her off message so close
to the finish line right now from their
perspective the goal is just to stay out
of trouble you know through tonight
through maybe another state or two she's
going to be within a couple hundred
points after tonight so on the Clinton
Robbie um M has it m and John pz when
they're sitting down when right their
list of troubles what's on their list of
of troubles right now you mean is Bill
Clinton on their list of troubles no
just anything I mean it seems like
things are going pretty well for them
right now actually things are going
great for them right now by all accounts
and she's having trouble sort of
containing how good she feels about that
there is still of course the FBI
investigation out there and now some
chance that it will not be resolved in
his timely fashion as earlier thought
it's still a big thing that's hanging
out always with the gmen it it is oh
thanks to Margaret talf um resplendent
in the color of money over there and
John McCormack slightly less resplendent
in Co Midwestern he does looks great
fantastic but you know not color of
money anyway coming up we're going to
talk about independent presidential
candidates in a two-party world after
this very brief itty bitty
[Music]
break
[Applause]
[Music]
John and I recently sat down with Peter
akan he's the chairman of the group
known as level the playing field it
wants to make it easier for third party
or independent candidates to participate
in presidential debates he was also the
founder of Americans elect which fought
to get an independent ticket on the
presidential ballot in 2012 for the
general election we started off by
asking Mr arrian if the success of
Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders this
year run contrary to his argument that
the two-party process is closed off to
Outsiders if you look at Bernie Sanders
you look at Don Trump the thing that
they don't have together is that they
don't represent an independent voice
that's simultaneously attractive to
Democrats that are moderate Republicans
that are moderate and
Independence together that Coalition is
not represented in either of them and
what we really need is a pathway so
people who can represent that Coalition
have a fair chance to compete are are
you sure that there's room for some
someone to be a distinctive voice and an
important voice between the two major
parties as opposed to Bernie Sanders on
the left and and Donald Trump on the
populist right well I think when you try
to conceptualize the third as fitting in
ideological crease between them you're
really missing the point an independent
today uh basically has a a whole range
of preferences tempered by intensity of
feeling about those preferences and when
you put that all together in terms of
portfolio of interests and and desires
they find the two parties are really
unsuitable to match one of the other to
match what they really want so this is
why 80% of the country today would love
to see a viable third people remember
American's elect and what it was trying
to do get a third party independent
candidacy create ballot access get
people on the ballot talk about level
the playing field and how it grew out of
that experience and what you're actually
trying to do right now well when we
created Americans elect the idea was to
create a uh an a uh internet-based
voting system that would nominate a
nonpartisan ticket not Republican not
Democrat that would be on the ballot in
all 50 states and we got a lot of that
done we did the largest signature Drive
in history we basically created the
ability for 40 million people to vote
but frankly and this was my problem as
the leaders I underestimated the
difficulty in getting into the debates
and so when we went to candidates and
asked them to consider running and they
go to their friends in the two parties
and ask well what do you think of that
and they would find that they had a
finger point there just saying that
would be bad for you they come back to
me and say hey Pete you know it's great
to um be able to try this for the first
time but if I put myself out I'm going
to get a lot of negative blowback if I
win I'm going to be uh on the ballot
which is cool but how do I get into the
debates and after two and a half years
of trying I didn't
plan I I just thought it was easier than
it was what we found was that there is
mathematically no chance of somebody
getting into the debates who wasn't a
Democrat Republican or an independent
that can can completely self funded even
they would have huge huge risks of
hurdling what's required to be in the
debates and so if I said to your uh your
viewers right now let's create a law
that only Democrats Republicans for the
pendency of our Republic can be uh can
be president I'd say every one of your
viewers without exception would say well
that's a terrible idea it's
unconstitutional it's probably in it's
an obnoxious thing to suggest but
mathematically because of the way the
debate rules are structured that's
precisely what we're going to get and
now we are fighting that we have a uh so
a motion for summary judgment against
the Federal Election Commission to force
the rules to be changed so level of
playing field is really just strictly
focused on the debate issue and the
things that come before it that the
logical adju of that for example the
ballot access rules and the imbalances
for example and how you could raise
money so if you're a Democrat or
Republican as George Clooney indicated
you can raise
$834,000 a person but if you're an
independent you could raise $2,700 a
person and so if you have to go out and
get on the the ballot which Democrats
republican nominees don't in every
single state it's a $15 million bill
I've been through it I know it when it's
all in so if you're if you're really at
$2,700 the reality is you're Gathering
if you're four times better than Bernie
Sanders $100 a person that means before
you get any name recognition you have to
sit down with people like I am with you
now and you'd have to sit down with
150,000 people assuming they'd all say
yes if half said yes it's 300,000 that's
why no individual who is not a
billionaire
has ever made it on the ballot for
president and that is an effect in our
system that really in in this day and
age must be rectified I understand what
you're doing and as I suggested before I
have a great um intellectual sympathy
for it but isn't the reality that
however much progress you have until
there's a person who can actually do
this has the political abilities the
kind of issues Matrix the funding
capacity either self-funding or the
ability to raise money like Bernie
Sanders uh nothing you do will matter
matter and if there is such a person you
might be Paving the way for them but
they won't really need this they'll be
able to on their own make these things
happen well under the current rules
there's no chance so let's take your
Bernie Sanders you know Bernie Sanders
was asked by your friend Chuck Todd well
um you are an independent socialist why
are you running as a Democrat and he
said because you wouldn't be
interviewing me today you've also noted
that Donald Trump has gotten $2 billion
of free earned media when you go through
the two parties you have a process that
you follow brilliantly for the both of
you to a normal conclusion of
anticipation of events and you talk
about it every day and that creates
earned media that allows an orderly stop
you they take take Trump had Trump
decided last May that he wanted to get
on all 50 state boutots and run as an
independent and was willing to spend his
own money and raise some money he he
would meet every standard he'd be on the
all 50 BS he'd be in the debates well
let's see if that's true I think the
important takeaway here is that just
like we're seeing now with the two
parties is that we're now seeing how
obscure rules that we don't see that we
don't think about until the moment we
need to think about them actually can
impact an election so much so that
people in the abstract at the end or
before now can say this is a rig game or
it's not
Democratic our thanks to Peter Akerman
John and I will be right
[Music]
back
[Applause]
[Music]
funny funny check out Bloomberg
politics.com for all the primary results
this evening coming up on Bloomberg West
Emily Chang speaks to the T-Mobile CEO
John Ledger on tomorrow's program here
our Pals at purple strategy Steve
McMahon and Alex casianos will join us
in Washington until
then hey hey there's one last thing
before we go last night in my home
burough Bruce Spring in concert at the
Barkley Center the governor of New
Jersey Chris Christie former
presidential candidate was spotted
gyrating gyrating The Audience by not
one but several cell phone cameras in
the annal of History this Christian
motion is right next to his orange
sweater celebration at that Cowboys game
Governor Christie just remember when
we're out in the
street we'll be waiting for you now
[Music]
sayara